precisamente esta noche en directo Ah
vamos a Florida de Estados Unidos el
gobernador ronda santis instó a la
ciudadanía a tomar precauciones ante la
llegada del huracán Ian y que se prevé
entrará al territorio como fenómeno de
categoría 4 en Miami está nuestro
corresponsal alto nivelchi con toda la
información Anthony Un saludo para
ustedes y comienzo preguntándole Qué se
sabe de la trayectoria Y qué se espera
con la llegada de día
muy buenas noches muy pendientes de esa
trayectoria del huracán y ya han De
hecho aquí en Miami a pesar de no estar
en el cono del pronóstico del Centro
Nacional de Huracanes sí que se empiezan
a notar los efectos de este huracán
irían un huracán que ya tocó tierra en
la madrugada De este lunes en el oeste
de Cuba dejando fuertes de lluvias
inundaciones y también un panorama
catastrófico ahora se dirige hacia el
estado de Florida y se espera que agarre
más fuerza en el golfo de México y
podría tocar tierra a primera hora de la
tarde del miércoles Con vientos de hasta
250 kilómetros por hora y convertido en
un potente huracán de categoría 4 por
eso las autoridades están pidiendo a la
población extremar todas las
precauciones pues hablemos de esas
precauciones Anthony En qué consisten
los preparativos para que la ciudadanía
se proteja y que han dicho sobre ese
respecto a las autoridades
Ángela las autoridades han dicho han
pedido la población extremar todas las
precauciones Especialmente cuando llegue
esa peligrosa a tormenta básicamente
porque los equipos de emergencia ni
siquiera van a poder salir a realizar
operativos el gobernador de Florida como
apuntabas ha dicho que esta tormenta es
muy peligrosa de hecho se han cerrado la
mayor parte de los distintos escolares
han cerrado las escuelas este miércoles
y jueves y se vuelve a ver esa imagen en
los supermercados de muchísima gente
acudiendo a comprar agua productos o no
perecederos también baterías y sobre
todo
bolsas de arena porque se espera que en
algunos o puntos alcance el nivel del
agua hasta tres metros además de 3
millones de personas han recibido
han recibido orden obligatoria y
voluntaria de evacuación sobre todo las
personas Viven cerca de la costa un
agradecimiento para usted Anthony y
seguimos atentos al desarrollo también
le deseo que tenga feliz noche y que se
cuide